oh Gott bald ist wieder Halloween der
einzige Tag der mir noch mehr auf die
Nüsse geht als Karneval warum erstens
die Kostüme sind scheiße überhaupt nicht
gruselig sorry Kinder aber wenn ihr mir
Angst machen wollt reicht weiße Farbe im
Gesicht nicht ich gehe jeden Mittwoch in
die seniorensauna da laufen Zombies rum
meine Fresse zweitens keiner braucht
haufenweise billige Süßigkeiten es gibt
doch weiß Gott genug fette Kinder klein
war hat mir keiner einfach so süß Kram
geschenkt deshalb bin ich auch heute
noch rank und schlank womit ich bei
drittens bin ich habe keinen Bock
ständig vom Sofa aufzustehen also ihr
kleinen Pratzen wer bei mir an der Tür
klingelt während ich alte Bergdoktor
folgen in der Mediathek gucke der kriegt
die Höchststrafe eine alte Bergdoktor
Folge
mitgucken